my friend my friend sister went on
Facebook or maybe was Instagram whatever
social media and she goes hey I just
want to let everybody know beachbody.com
is not a pyramid scheme
okay there's a lot of misinformation out
there it's not a pimp net with Beachbody
is for those of you who don't know is
it's like this pyramid scheme clearly a
multi-level marketing scheme like Amway
or like anything else which is based on
you converting your dumb friends and
selling them [ __ ] because they're fat
and you go oh a group of friends we're
all gonna motivate each other better
than celebrities and trainers will umm
no your group of friends is why you're
fat you don't change with the group of
friends you get rid of them you get rid
of the fatties no G a group of friends
is the reason you're [ __ ] you're gonna
try to you're gonna try to change six
people's lives at once who the [ __ ] does
that so that that's the whole thing
about buy Beachbody and then you become
like a coach or a Beachbody Coach and
you put up all these motivational things
like it's 5:00 a.m. and I want to stay
in bed but I'm not cuz I'm a Beachbody
Coach now if you buy the the meals and
the shakes you too can be a Beachbody
Diamond member and and you just climb up
this but I love you
so Beachbody by the way of course had to
like address the idea that they were
this multi-level marketing thing okay
actually on their website they're
basically like listen we're not a
pyramid scheme wikipedia defines a
pyramid scheme is this does that sound
like what we're doing and then the
difference between what they do and what
an actual pyramid scheme is is literally
nothing and as you read it it's got a
cycle area Beachbody discusses pyramid
schemes in multi-level marketing right
this is great you may be asking is
Direct Selling
same as multi-level marketing is it a
pyramid scheme a Ponzi scheme is it a
scam how do people make money and what's
the opportunity for me lots of great
questions and we'll take one by one
simply put according to Wikipedia Direct
Selling is the marketing and selling of
products directly to consumers away from
a fixed retail location so it's the guy
that shows up opens his trunk and sells
you shed in other words that's not what
it says on Wikipedia I'm adding that in
this is what they say they go so what
about pyramid schemes a pyramid scheme
or Ponzi scheme is something completely
different and far more harmful like a
scam that's far more harmful it's like a
scam is Beachbody a pyramid scheme no
Team Beachbody Coaches make money from
actual sales of genuine fitness and
nutrition products and hard work not
from recruiting fees or business fees
coaches are never paid to recruit people
and do not earn money from recruiting
yet they earn money when they sell
people to [ __ ] our mission is to help
people live healthier more fulfilling
lives how do people become coaches do
they make money by selling Shakeology
our coaches start as customers right
holla pyramid scheme Beachbody once they
start to get results people tend to
notice and ask what they are doing no
one does that by the way people all you
look great you lost weight some people
go what are you doing you got I got
nobody wants to hear at that point
people only want to hear like a one-word
answer
Lokar slow carb keto paleo walk around
the block
I cut out booze nobody wants to hear
this I can't ask me you look a little
thinner what do you been doing you look
a little thinner what have you been
doing take a seat I've been waiting for
you to ask me this I'd become a member
of a very fulfilling new group that
holds each other accountable have you
heard of Shakeology
I haven't why are you looking at me like
that sit down and get ready for the
secret I'm about to tell you the secret
about Shakeology some companies have
used direct sales model
will you where are you going I just want
to talk about Shakeology do you have
your credit card on you we can get you
started right now they enjoy helping
others achieve the results they've
achieved using Beachbody products and
want to share with others so they sign
up to be coaches you could sign up to be
a coach for $40 dude we're doing this
$40 I could sign up to be a coach Plus
16 16 a month
here's Team Beachbody Coach Joan
Crocker's story she's been suffering
from depression and was gaining weight
her husband introduced her to Beachbody
she bought insanity and worked out hard
to the complete 60 day program she said
I found my confidence in happy again
and Happiness again I felt better
physically mentally and emotionally and
then I decided I wanted to rob others
here's team Jen Richards his story at
Beachbody she was two months postpartum
with her second son and searched for
teaching jobs where she could put her
master's degree to use but because the
country is a bag of [ __ ] she decided to
sell people fitness shakes because life
is a hell like that if this was honest
that's what it would really she tried to
use her master's degree but because she
couldn't find any work she decided it
was much more fulfilling to start
Hawking Fitness shakes to her friends
that was a much better way to go about
earning money sure she had her passion
was for education she wanted to teach
kids how to read but hey you know it's a
good close second teaching your fat
friend how to hawk shakes I would plunge
a knife in it my own throat before I
would sit down and have to look at
someone in the face and say the word
Shakeology if you say the word
Shakeology with a straight face you need
to be in a cell
yes--she college I love it
it's 6:00 a.m. I was gonna sleep in but
that's not what I'm about I just made a
quick shake and I'm ready to work out
burn some cows hey do you want to look
and feel good - we'll get your credit
card out cuz imma bet you want to come
on in you're gonna be a coach you start
as a fat [ __ ] but you end up a coach
don't you want to be a coat well I don't
have any skills shut up you're gonna be
a coach I don't really know anything
about nutrition and fitness it doesn't
matter
the people at Shakeology have provided
us with all the information we'll need
all you have to find is five other fat
Fox that a desperate that have
postpartum depression I love who this is
being marketed to
they're like genies story was great she
was laying on the floor of her trailer
who's this product for people that have
given up all hope Cheney was sitting in
her car with the engine on in her garage
she was three guests away from meeting
Jesus and then Cheney went inside and
she went and she saw that her good
friend at work had lost three pounds by
drinking shakes all day so Jeannie said
God her friend had posted on Facebook
that there was a unique money-making
opportunity in the fitness world Jeannie
had always wanted a beach body she never
had one she had died you know scar she
had a stretch marks it looked like
spiders crawling up her stomach but she
wanted that beach body so she saw one of
her friends on Facebook oh hey are you
laying on the floor of your apartment
thinking of reasons not to kill yourself
maybe you should become a Beachbody
Coach you can look good and feel good I
love who this is marketed to let's keep
going on the by the way I wonder if any
of them were like this person was doing
good and they decided to get involved or
is everybody as well gun in their mouth
before they decide which of course you
have to to lower
yourself to this to lower yourself to
Hawking fitness shakes to your friends
it you have to be ready to kill yourself
hillary kelly remembers her early days
as a Team Beachbody Coach and how she
built her business you artwork I'm not a
nutrition expert but I started with the
simple approach of sharing my story both
in person and on Facebook here's how
that should have ended I'm not a
nutrition expert so I didn't get
involved end of post I'm not a nutrition
expert so I shut my mouth and went on my
merry way but no she decided she knows
I'm not a nutrition expert but I started
with a simple approach of sharing my
story both in person and on Facebook
I think people respond to that I had no
agenda except to help people get fit if
you break it down that's what this
business is all about yeah
these people talk in [ __ ] like
pamphlets you know right I had no agenda
says you did [ __ ] you seem a little
guilty doth protest too much they're
like it's not a pyramid scheme
I had no agenda I'm not [ __ ] yeah I
didn't do anything
I didn't go in your purse when you were
in the bathroom what are you saying what
do you mean there was $20 on the wallet
when I walked there you better talk to
Shakeology I love all of the [ __ ]
examples of people that they use she was
suffering from depression and was
gaining weight her husband introduced at
a Beachbody her husband was like listen
you fat sad [ __ ] you better clean it up
and you better start bringing in some
money into this house what a nice guy
huh he introduced her to Beachbody she's
depressed
he didn't introduce her to a doctor he
didn't introduce you to a therapist he
introduced you to a multi-level
marketing scam honey you seem depressed
you don't get out of bed all day why
don't you start Hawking Fitness plans
why don't you get yours monthly sales
numbers up that's why you feel like [ __ ]
because you're laying in bed every day
and not selling shakes to your friends I
love it so much I love it so much man I
love how everybody using this
is completely our Team Beachbody Coach
networkers over 400 thousand strong god
help us I gotta start doing this man now
by the way I'm gonna tell the audience
this if Beachbody contacts me and pays
me money I will sell Shakeology and I
will delete this episode I tell you that
all the time in full disclosure I give a
[ __ ] about you pigs I will I will shove
shakes down your throat so [ __ ] fast
you fat slobs I will put a shake in my
ass
if Beachbody tells me to if they want to
spend some [ __ ] money that's what I
do I really kill these companies to try
to get them I'll become a fitness coach
what I gotta make some motivational
Facebook posts God do that can easily do
that I used to be fat I used to eat
pizza not even good pizza like Papa
John's Domino's cuz I like to I felt in
my mouth warm and gooey like I was
eating my own insides anyway then I went
online and so a friend of mine was
marginally less fat and I asked her I
said hey fatty
are you less fat she said yes I said
what are you doing she goes well I'm
part of an online community that
provides me the support and the
nutrition products I need and I said
well get me in on the ground floor and
let's go and spread the word of
Shakeology